hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint moins vite
sur messenger
[Musique]
alors lé vigueur mais bien dégueulasse
c'est daniel ses basses oeuvres c'est ma
grand mère a même si ces compagnies ça
bonjour
sans le côté que la pluie
[Musique]
paris
vidéo gag sur ces 8 est une grande
nouvelle c'est vrai et puis c'est pas
des gars comme pas prendre ces sont les
chroniqueurs ou font des gaffes toute
l'année donc on va reprendre une sorte
de best of de leur émission envoyé et ce
sera formidable
[Musique]
le plus petit kilo d'aliment not least
tabary de l'exécution on a besoin de
prendre un microscope on l'interdît à
l'origine et le problème de la minutie
parfois des tours et que tout ce trail
qui font le buzz et valence l'astronome
john a bien sûr c'est que tu avales élus
tous rabat de la vallée
c'est à dire un base de couscous
houlette y aura un peu de blabla de la
malle à tous valérie quoi
[Musique]
je ne cacherai pas qui évidemment la
proposition m'a été faite j'en ai été
très flatté mais je peux pas je vois
reprendre le talk show d'oprah winfrey
ellen degeneres a commencé un petit peu
à fin juillet aussi aux states je
pourrais pas être sur tous les dossiers
donc courte et bmp désolé mais pour la
présentation sera pas plus mais
chroniqueuse de temps en temps way
[Musique]
ok
[Rires]
une belle est-ce qu'on est belle à la
fois toutes les réponses